la conmemoración de los 211 años del
inicio de la guerra de independencia de
mexico se llevó a cabo con un minuto de
silencio para empezar por parte del
presidente andrés manuel lópez obrador y
su esposa en memoria de las víctimas de
la pandemia de kobe 19 posteriormente el
mandatario salió al balcón de palacio
nacional frente a un zócalo vacío por
las medidas sanitarias y dio el
tradicional grito de independencia y
como ya es costumbre le agregó algunas
frases en esta ocasión algunas de ellas
fueron viva la fraternidad universal
viva el amor al prójimo y vivan en los
pueblos las culturas del méxico
prehispánico
posteriormente se proyectaron unos vídeo
mapping 1 sobre la pirámide del templo
mayor esta réplica que se colocó el
zócalo capitalino para proyectar algunos
pasajes de la fundación de méxico
tenochtitlán
asimismo sobre la catedral metropolitana
se proyectó otro vídeo mapping con
pasajes de la independencia de mexico el
cierre de esta festividad corrió a cargo
de la cantante lila downs quien
interpretó la canción latinoamérica de
calle 13 aunque el primer cuadro de la
ciudad de mexico del centro histórico
estuvo cerrado al público decenas de
familias intentaron aproximarse lo más
que pudieron para presenciar el
espectáculo de juegos pirotécnicos y la
música tradicional mexicana